Cat Williams just called out the entire
comedy industry including Kevin Hart
Steve Harvey and even Joe Rogan that
would be like me being on Joe Rogan Joe
don't want me on there I need to be on
Shannon Joe got six comedians that never
been funny he want to push out this
interview has blown up online not just
in the comedy world but viral everywhere
with 20 million views in 3 days and the
comics in question have slowly started
to respond Kevin Hart said got to get
that anger out of there champ it's
honestly sad Joe Rogan respond resped by
saying I love cat he's one of my
favorite comics and I'd love to have him
on we talk about him all the time if
he's down I'll make it happen and Mark
Norman chimed in with a classic Zinger
Cat Williams just dropped the black
Epstein Client List it'll be interesting
to see who else responds after